You've been taught to trade fair value
gaps completely wrong. Let me ask you
something. Would you buy here on this
so-called fair value gap perfect
pullback? Most traders that learn how to
use fair value gaps do. They see price
pullback into this fair value gap zone
and they instantly buy for a
continuation trade. But here's the
truth. Today I made a little over $1,100
and yesterday I made $2,800 by doing the
complete opposite of what most videos
teach you how to do. With one simple
shift in how you approach fair value
gaps, everything changes. Your trades
get cleaner, your confidence goes up,
and your losses start disappearing. Let
me first show you what fair value gaps
are, how to properly use them, and then
how to properly profit trading using
them. First off, fair value gaps help
you identify when the market has made a
drastic move in one direction. And how
most traders trade these is they look to
buy when the market comes back and
retests this area of a drastic move
higher. And from what I've learned is
that is the completely wrong way to do
it. Now the basics of how they work is
you can have a bullish or bearish fair
value gap and it takes three
candlesticks to identify one. The whole
idea is you take the high and then
there's a massive candle in this case a
bullish candle one direction and then
you take the low of the third candle and
the gap between that high and that low
make that fair value gap. buyers here
have pushed the price so quickly that it
is an unhealthy move that it's likely
that the price and sellers will want to
essentially retest this gap area. Same
thing on the flip side in a bearish way.
All you're doing is just taking instead
the low and the high of the first and
third candle and the gap between those
two creates that fair value gap. And so
the nice thing is most platforms have a
fair value gap indicator and so they
will automatically draw the bearish or
the bullish fair value gaps on your
chart so you can easily identify them.
Now what most people try and do is they
try and trade them with the trend. They
see that oh there is a fair value gap
right here and I want to buy when it
comes down and tests that and pushes
higher. Now, the problem with this is a
lot of the time the market will break
through that fair value gap before it
bounces. It'll bounce midway through the
fair value gap or it'll blow all the way
past that. It's really hard to
profitably know where to enter in on a
trade and put your stop loss if you're
just waiting for the market to come down
to a random price. And so instead, what
I've realized over time is this is a
great example right here is when you
have a ton of fair value gaps popped up
is that it's actually likely to reverse
and you can find a very clean reversal
trade instead of looking for a
continuation trade because in the really
strong markets if you see right here is
it it just goes up. it'll continue
higher and it won't really pull back
allowing you to jump in on that trend
before the trend really starts to slow
down and it's not really in a good spot.
A lot of the times it'll just shoot up
higher and then by the time there's a
chance to get in it'll just go sideways
or the trend will be already over. So,
let me walk you through two real trades
now to help illustrate and show you how
to properly do this in real time. These
are both trades I took that actually
have live trading recordings of them.
You can go watch me find these trades
and take them in real time, but I'll
quickly walk you through them now to
save you time and also explain this
concept more. Those will have a lot more
detailed interesting insights to what
it's like actually executing this in
real time. But let me walk you through
some basics of how to do this first and
what you're looking for when you're
taking these trades. Now the biggest
thing that I have learned from using
fair value gaps is to look for reversals
instead of looking for a continuation.
So how I use them is I essentially see
the fair value gap indicator pop up. And
to me what that says is that this market
is overextended
to the downside and it needs to reverse.
and that these overextensions are great
targets for when you jump in a trade and
catch a reversal based on that. That's
the power of using these with a few key
steps that we're going to go over. But
when I was trading this, the biggest
thing that I like to see with these is a
previous clear support resistance level.
So, if we kind of zoom out and look at
the big picture as the market's kind of
selling off down here, I'm thinking,
okay, what is a clean area that I think
that it's going to bounce down here is a
good level. And I would say over here is
a pretty good level, too, because we had
this big crazy move and this was
basically yesterday's low. And so,
that's why that to me was a worthwhile
level to pay attention to. And so coming
into this, that's what I was looking for
was well, okay, we have this big move
down. So that's the first thing that
kind of keys me into, okay, pay
attention here and these big fair value
gaps indicators are popping off too. And
then if I actually go into a recording
of the trade on a one minute chart, this
is that move down and that support level
that I'm looking at. I'm looking for the
market to break this downtrend line.
It's pretty clearly done that. and then
essentially catch a double bottom here.
And so what happens is the market
essentially double bottoms here. I like
that idea of we're in an area to look
for a bottom. And so just to kind of
zoom this through because I just want to
show you some quick overview and then
we'll get into a few key factors in a
second of really what make this super
powerful. This trade I actually took
small size because it wasn't a really
really good crystal clear setup for
using the fair value gaps. This next
trade I'll really show you the power of
it but just to show you how this one
played out is I had a couple of targets
here is you know mid-range of
essentially this is where those fair
value gaps were. I was targeting
essentially two times my risk as a
profit. And then this one was, you know,
if it just shoots up, I'll take some off
there if it gets all the way up there.
Um eventually what happened is I got out
half at two times and then it kind of
slowly moved up, slowly kind of started
to sit there and slow down. And so I
essentially trailed up and closed out
with closing out for about $1,100 total
on this trade. closing out the first and
the second half of that trade. And so
that's the trade I took today. So this
is a decent setup on a 5m minute. It's
got a really nice clear double bottom.
And so that's the couple factors that
are really important when it comes to
this. The biggest thing is yesterday I
went three times that size on this trade
right here because of a few key factors
that weren't in the last trade. And so
just to kind of zoom out to look at this
to kind of show you, well, this was what
I was looking at before. We had a big
move up here. And so kind of just
zooming out, there was a big all-time
high right here. And so pulling that
resistance zone over as this market kind
of popped up into this, I'm thinking,
okay, look at these moves. The market
opens up right here at 7:30 my time. So
the market opens up and instantly
skyrockets higher making massive fair
value gaps pop up and multiple of them.
If you compare this one to this trade
over here that I took today is you know
there were some fair value gaps and it
had a nice move down but there wasn't a
massive red box here of clear
overextension. And if I actually go to a
one minute chart of what this looks like
and and I actually traded this on the ES
instead of the NASDAQ, but you can see
it's pretty similar. There's a bunch of
overextended boxes. I'm not going to get
into why I traded the ES over the
NASDAQ. If you watch the live stream
recording of this, you'll hear why, but
essentially, you can see here the market
just kind of shoots up in about honestly
20 minutes. It makes a massive move up.
I'll pull up the recording of this now.
As you can see, it's coming up right
into that resistance zone that I'm
looking at. And I really sized up on
this trade because of a few key factors.
And now, let me kind of give you a deep
dive into the checklist I use for each
one of these trade entries and how to
know why the fair value gap is going to
really reverse versus, you know, before
a lot of people will try and see that
fair value gap and kind of buy here
looking for it to go long. And sometimes
that'll happen and I'll avoid those
trades because of a few key factors.
Also, if you're wondering what trading
platform I'm using, it's called Ninja
Trader. I've used it for over 5 years.
It's amazing. I'll leave a link in the
description below this video if you want
to check it out. You need just the
basics of this fair value gap to be
popping off. And the biggest thing is
having a bunch of them compared to the
trade today I took. That'll really
increase your confidence because when
the market whips up that high that fast,
it's really likely to give it back up
because of remember that imbalance in
the market. That's what really makes
this so powerful and allows you to when
you trade to enter in and risk a smaller
amount or have a good riskreward ratio
to where you can be risking, you know,
$100, $1,000, doesn't matter what your
size is, but you're going for three
times your risk. That's a massive key
when it comes to trading. For me, I have
found that's way easier to be successful
at. And so, kind of the first thing is
you want those fair value gap
indicators. And then second is coming up
to this resistance zone. You have to
have a key level to be trading these off
of. You do not want to be just trading
them randomly. Here's a clean example of
really just right before this trade
happened is where there's this is big
indicator of overextension, right? But
you can see there is if we kind of zoom
out, there's not really a good clean
level. There's kind of something here,
but if you really zoom out, that's
middle of the range. The good extreme
levels down here. I'm not going to go
over how to draw key levels in this
video. I'll link a video up here on how
to do that properly. But that is why and
a reason why you want to stay from away
from something like this because there
isn't a good zone to reverse off of. You
need to be waiting for there to be a
really clean zone like this and then
going into a one minute chart because I
like to trade on a one minute chart
right when the market opens. I'll take a
5minut entry a little later sometimes or
if the market's a little slower but in
this case I took it on a 1 minute
because it made a really nice setup. Now
another huge factor in this trade is
there was timing. I have three kind of
timing windows I look for and the window
this one aligned up was 30 minutes after
the market opens. I constantly see
reversals happen at that time. And so
this is a another catalyst on what makes
this a really good setup. And then kind
of the final thing is, you know, you
have this uptrend that's broken, but a
big thing is looking at the structure of
the highs and the lows, the swings. And
so here, you know, in an uptrend, it's
making higher highs and higher lows. And
so I need to see that stop and it make a
lower high. This is a massive key factor
here. And so from that point, that's
when I look to jump in the trade.
Sometimes I'll look and say, okay, I
like a fivem minute better, but the five
minute kind of just chopped here pretty
good, too. So when I was actually
trading this, this took a long time to
get going. On a 5m minute, it looks
pretty simple. But on a one minute, it
took about 20 30 minutes to get going.
And when I was trading larger than
normal size, I put $1,400 of risk on
this trade. My kind of normal large size
is a,000. And because this was such a
good setup, I did a little extra because
of how confident I was in it. And so it
makes just the waiting even that much
worse. And so eventually they'll punch
down here, move to break even, and set a
limit order here at two times my risk.
Essentially, a good target is the bottom
of the main move. That's the easy money
if you ask me. And then after that, my
thought is, okay, I will trail this
thing and let it keep going if it's
going to keep going. But if it has a big
pullback like it just did, I'm going to
get out and call it a day. Now, if you
want a 14page free trading strategy
guide of this strategy and the
candlestick patterns I follow, you can
check that out in the link in the
description below. And if you want a
detailed walkthrough of how to draw
these support and resistance levels,
those are really the key to massively
improving your win rate, check out this
video right here.